[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Hello.
Welcome to the fourth
episode of our
"Women Techmakers" series.
This is the series to share the
stories of women who are
luminaries in the tech world,
and to inspire more women to
enter technology.
And there's lots of resources
in our Google Developer
network to learn how
to do just that.
Today, I'm thrilled to be here
with a very special guest, and
a great co-host.
But our guest is Diane Green, a
Google board member and the
founder of a couple of
companies, but more recently,
founder and former
CEO of VMware.
So we'll have Diane introduce
herself in a minute.
I'm Claire Hughes Johnson.
I lead our Google
Offers product.
I've been at Google for
almost nine years.
And I've worked on a variety
of products, on both the
consumer and the business
product side, in both sales
and product.
So, I have a little bit of
a different background.
I live in Menlo Park and I have
two lovely children and
husband named Jesse.
Which is interesting,
because my co-host
today is named Jessie.
And I would love Jessie Jiang
to introduce herself.
[JESSIE JIANG]
Great.
Thank you, Claire.
My name is Jessie Jiang.
I'm a product management
director in
Google Cloud Platform.
Google Cloud Platform provide
a set of services for
developers to build
and run their
applications in Google's Cloud.
Some of our products include
Google App Engine, Google
Compute Engine, storage, Cloud
SQL, and BigQuery.
I've been at Google for
about seven years,
not as long as Claire.
It's always been very
exciting to be here.
I have a daughter.
She is four years old.
I actually think your
son and my daughter
go to the same school.
Anyway, I'm very excited to be
here today and to be part of
this interview with Diane.
I'm sure she has some really
inspiring stories to share
with all of us.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
So with that, let's hear from
Diane Greene, a little bit of
your background would
be great.
[DIANE GREENE]
OK.
Hello, I'm Diane Greene, and
it's great to be here.
And I actually started
as an engineer.
I have a degree in mechanical
engineering and Naval
architecture.
And I worked in the oil and
shipping industry for a while,
before I decided to go back to
school and study computer
science, and have a computer
science degree.
And then moved in the tech,
probably 25 years ago.
And worked in the industry
in the database and
a little bit hardware.
And in, let's see, 1995 I
started doing start-ups.
and I've done three start-ups.
The first was a low-bandwidth
video streaming start-up, that
Microsoft bought and
became the basis
for their Movie Player.
And another one was in internet
ad serving, a company
called AdForce.
And then the last one was
VMware, which I started the
same year Google was founded.
And co-founded with
four other people.
And stayed with VMware
for 11 years.
Got it to about $2 billion
and about 7,000 people.
And it's a virtualization
company.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
And were you the CEO for the--
[DIANE GREENE]
Yes, I was the CEO--
founding CEO of VMware and built
the company as the CEO.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Wow.
We're very lucky to
have Diane here.
We thought we'd start with
a little bit about the
innovation and the technology
that was behind VMware.
And I would love to have Jessie
lead this section,
since she works on this type
of work at Google.
[JESSIE JIANG]
Yeah, this is why I'm so excited
to be here today.
Cloud computing is one
of the biggest trends
in technology today.
And virtualization is
in the center of it.
VMware obviously is a pioneer
in virtualization.
You co-founded the company and
were the CEO for many years.
So maybe we can start by having
you tell us a little
bit about your story there.
[DIANE GREENE]
Well, we had this insight.
There was research going on at
Stanford by my co-founder and
husband, Mendel Rosenblum,
around revisiting the idea of
virtualization.
IBM had done it in the '60s for
different reasons, when
computers were extraordinarily
expensive
and a precious resource.
And we had the idea that it
would be useful for all kinds
of compartmentalization and
providing levels of
indirection--
and we can go more into that.
But if we brought it to
mainstream processors, to the
Intel processor, and so
we decided to do that.
It was difficult, because
virtualization had died out.
The Intel processor had no
hardware support for
virtualization because people
thought it was a
thing of the past.
But we got it working on the
Intel processor, and were able
to bring it to market.
And it did become the basis of
the large virtualization
industry, that's right.
[JESSIE JIANG]
That's great.
So, I actually heard a little
bit about this story.
But I think that one of very
interesting things about
VMware, is, it's actually
started as a company that much
more focused on the
client side.
And I think I also heard that
you have always known that the
server side is where the
future of VMware
was going to be.
So maybe you can delve a little
bit more into that
story, and see how you decided
your first step.
And then how you lead the
company to become successful
on the server side.
[DIANE GREENE]
Sure.
We thought this virtualization
was incredibly useful.
And we thought, from day one,
that it was really needed on
the servers as a way to
provide isolation.
The operating systems were only
running one application
per operating system
at the time.
And that was wasting.
Machines were running
about 5% to 10%.
And there were security and
fault isolation problems, and
all kinds of resource
isolation problems.
But we knew we couldn't go into
the enterprise with a
product that ran everybody's
software.
And have people trust
us, and to play us.
And we had to get a lot
of credibility.
So we came up with an
architecture where we would
take advantage of the Windows
operating system on the
desktop for all its
device drivers.
And we decided to
introduce it.
Right then, LINUX was getting
a lot of attraction.
And we knew that all the
developers running LINUX
needed a way to run their
Windows applications, this is
back in '98, '99.
And so we introduced it as
a way to run Windows
applications, while you
were running LINUX.
And be able to run them
side by side.
With the idea that these
developers would give us great
bug reports.
[JESSIE JIANG]
That's a good idea.
[DIANE GREENE]
And so we launched
it as a desktop.
But I have to say that we did
a vision statement when we
founded the company.
And in it we said,
oh, this will be
ubiquitous by the year 2000.
We were off by a few years.
But it did become ubiquitous.
[JESSIE JIANG]
That's great.
So, we were actually talking
about some of the other
virtualization technology right
before this started,
like XEN and KVM,
and all that.
And cloud computing, in general,
is really, in many
ways, are changing how people
are doing things.
So what do you feel
like the cloud
computing trend is going?
What do you think are
some of the--
predicting what the next set of
new innovations that might
come up, either in the field
of cloud computing, or as a
result of the cloud computing?
[DIANE GREENE]
Well, there's a lot of major
changes going on, as I think
we all know.
We're all involved in a
very exciting time.
In the infrastructure,
in the hardware
space, there's all kinds.
People are rebuilding the
hardware to be optimized for
virtualization--
virtualized storage, virtualized
networking.
And that's all very active.
And at the system level, ways to
manage a data center where
it looks like one big compute
resource using, and
oftentimes, the virtualization.
But the cloud, part of what's
making this cloud, so exciting
is that all of a sudden, all the
data and compute is in a
place where you can access
it from anywhere--
from any device.
And the devices have
a lot of sensors.
And so human-computer
interaction is becoming much
more human-like.
And the cloud, with the
mobile devices,
is making it possible.
And there's some big
trends there.
[JESSIE JIANG]
That's right.
So let me just ask one more
cloud computing question.
And then I'm going to turn
this to Claire, because I
think that a lot of people are
probably eager to hear about
your stories on being
entrepreneur, leadership and
management.
So, VMware is a very, very
successful enterprise company.
And you have a lot of experience
in terms of working
enterprises.
Given the trend in cloud
computing, and some of the
other technology innovations,
how do you think that
enterprise should approach their
technology these days?
Are there things you feel like
they should do differently?
[DIANE GREENE]
Well, enterprises are trying to
build data centers that are
cost effective.
And they're trying to centralize
all their services.
So it's easier to administer and
have single sign-on, have
a single view of all the
data, and so forth.
And the support to build a
data center with the cost
effectiveness of the big
services like Google, like
Amazon, and so forth,
is not there yet.
But that is what enterprises
are trying to do.
And more and more, they're going
to be able to get these
services from external hosting
providers, external providers.
And some of the challenges of
running these hosting centers,
around security, around
up-time and cost
effectiveness, I think, are
going to push people to using
external providers.
Because that's where the
expertise in how to do this,
is going to be the highest.
I think it's getting to the
point where security is such a
tough problem.
That unless you let the experts,
each company can't
have enough expertise to
protect themselves.
And it needs to get more
sophisticated.
And it will when the talent's
centralized, I think.
[JESSIE JIANG]
That's a great point.
Very exciting.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Great.
Well, let's come back to this.
But let's talk a little bit
about one thing you mentioned,
which is the decision to go back
to school and to work in
computer science.
So, what led you to
that decision?
[DIANE GREENE]
Well, it was interesting.
I was working.
I love adventures and I
love being outside.
And I had gone into
the oil industry.
and I was wanting to go to these
offshore oil platforms
in the North Rankin sea, off
the coast of Australia.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Those platforms that
catch on fire?
[DIANE GREENE]
I actually got to work on
[INAUDIBLE] their mooring
system for putting an oil rig
out from a semi-submersible
oil platform.
At one point.
It was very interesting.
But anyhow, they had no quarters
for women at the
time, out on these platforms.
And I was stuck doing all
the computer analysis.
Which I thought, well there's
more interesting things to do
with computers than
hydro-dynamics analysis.
And so I decided.
When I had been studying Naval
architecture, I'd hung out at
MIT with a lot of artificial
intelligence people.
And I'd been really
interested in it.
And I decide to go back to
school and study it.
So I went back to Berkeley and
studied computer science.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Because you thought there could
be more than just the
data analysis piece.
You to do more and--
[DIANE GREENE]
Well, it just seemed like
computers were starting to get
so capable that it was clearly
revolutionizing our lives.
And I wanted to be a
part of it, yeah.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
And then when you co-founded
VMware with your husband, he
was a professor?
[DIANE GREENE]
No, we were both--
oh yeah, well yes.
I met my husband at Berkeley
where we were
both graduate students.
And then we co-founded the
company when he was a
professor at Stanford, right.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
I think you've told
this story--
[DIANE GREENE]
And he still is.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
--About how you stepped
in and said, well
I'll help run things.
And then you ended
up being CEO.
What do you think?
How do it go from, well, I'll
help out, to realizing you
were the best person
to be the CEO?
[DIANE GREENE]
Yeah, well, I had already been
the CEO of a start-up, and I'd
been involved in two.
And I felt very comfortable
getting them going.
And I said OK.
And I really thought
this was something
worth bringing to market.
I actually pushed.
I said, let's bring
this to market.
This is really valuable.
But then I discovered
I was pregnant.
And so I said, well I
will help you get
this out the door.
I know how to build
a start-up.
And then we'll have to find
someone, because I'm about to
have my second kid.
And what it turned out was, it
was very easy to have my
second kid and build
the company.
All in--
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Because you were the boss.
[DIANE GREENE]
Yeah, so it worked out.
And I always said, if I didn't
think I was adding value, I
would leave.
But it just went really well.
We all liked each other.
We were all making lots of
progress all the time.
And so I--
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
So your daughter's the
same age as VMware?
[DIANE GREENE]
Exactly.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
And you would bring her into
work occasionally, or when she
was little?
[DIANE GREENE]
She came into work a lot.
I brought her all over
the world with me.
I would always hire a
really good nanny in
whatever city I went to.
So that she would have more fun
than me sometimes, getting
to go out and see the city.
She learned origami in Japan
from her nannies.
It was really a great
experience for her.
And both of my kids
are pretty savvy.
They always surprise us with how
much they know about how a
tech company might be built.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Well, they saw it from
the ground up.
[DIANE GREENE]
Well, they just heard about
nothing else since the day
they were born.
[JESSIE JIANG]
That's probably what
happened,yes.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
So, when you think about your
leadership style, and really
scaling with VMware, right, from
start-up world to a much
larger company--
an enterprise.
Maybe you can talk about, what
were some of the lessons you
learned, or how you had to flex
and adapt as a leader.
[DIANE GREENE]
Yeah.
It was really a nice way to
scale up as a leader, because
it was so incremental with
the people that we hired.
And one of the things I did was,
we had a lunch we brought
in once a week.
And talked to everybody
about what was
going on in the company.
And I wasn't that comfortable
speaking in public when we
started the company.
But it got bigger by a few
people every week, and pretty
soon it was a 1,000 people.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
At lunch?
[DIANE GREENE]
Yeah, well.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Probably evolved.
[DIANE GREENE]
Probably about 500.
We couldn't have everybody
in one place.
But that really scaled up.
And then certainly, when you're
doing something like
that, it's a constant process of
figuring out what you don't
need to do anymore and hiring
someone else to do it.
And constantly shedding
responsibilities.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
And how much did you stay
involved in the technology and
the thinking about what the
product was going to be and
how it was going to evolve?
[DIANE GREENE]
Well, I always, all
the way through,
attended product meanings.
And I felt like I couldn't run
the company if I didn't really
have a very grounded
understanding of
what we were doing.
And I felt like I was helpful
in the product review.
Not every product meeting, but
the major product reviews
about a new product or
a new direction.
Because I was out
in the field.
I was seeing all aspects
of how I was
working with the partners.
And so that was a valuable
perspective for
those product meetings.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Because as CEO, you were
particularly external and
probably talking to
a lot of large
partners, or large customers?
[DIANE GREENE]
I was very focused really
internally on the culture.
I cared a great deal
about that.
But I also thought partners were
so key to our being able
to build the business.
And I really enjoyed working
with other companies, and both
of us winning together.
And so I stayed very active with
our hardware partners.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Got it.
And when you think about whether
it was-- maybe it was
a partner or a mentor--
but somebody who guided you as
you went through this process.
Were there particular types of
people that you turned to?
I often hear that women
feel they don't
have a lot of examples.
And I don't think the example
or the mentor has to be a
woman, necessarily.
But I don't know if you had
any people that played an
important role.
[DIANE GREENE]
I watched everywhere.
When we were playing with the
hardware companies, I got to
work with a lot of senior
executives.
And I would say, particularly
at IBM, I learned a lot from
being with those executives.
They were very sophisticated,
and really had a very
360-degree view of what
they were doing.
And so I, in particular, tried
to spend more time with some
of those executives sometimes.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
That's a great idea.
Was there any woman in
particular who looked to, or
did you just have to
just pave the way?
[DIANE GREENE]
I was going to say no.
But then I remembered
that Sue Whitney
was running the hardware--
all the server stuff, the X86
server stuff-- at IBM.
And I got to be friends
with her.
That was good.
[JESSIE JIANG]
So, VMware was the second
company that you started.
You had another one
before that.
Do you like comparing the first
one and then VMware.
Do you feel like there was a
difference between doing it a
first time, versus doing
it a second time?
[DIANE GREENE]
Yeah, there was a huge
difference doing
it the second time.
The first time was great..
But we had a vague idea, and we
all started working on it.
And as we got into the company,
it became clear that
we all-- our vague idea--
everybody had internalized a
little bit differently.
And it caused for a little bit
of dysfunction in the company.
And so the first thing I did
when we started VMware was
write our mission and vision.
And have everybody edit
it and sign off on it
before we kept going.
So I knew we were all on the
same page, and I found that
very helpful.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
That's a good tip.
[JESSIE JIANG]
Yeah, I assume you also made a
lot of effort to make sure
those visions are communicated
to all the people in VMware as
the company becomes
bigger and bigger.
[DIANE GREENE]
Yeah, someone once told me you
can never over-communicate,
and I've really taken
that to heart.
You can say things over and over
again, and people don't
seem to get tired
of hearing it.
You get tired of listening.
You just worry about boring
them, but it turns out that
important things can be said in
many, many different ways,
over and over again.
And so, we did work very hard on
keeping everybody in sync.
In fact one thing I used to
always like to do is to be the
last on an interview schedule.
And ask the person, well what
did everybody tell you about
our strategy.
And find out--
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Another good tip.
[DIANE GREENE]
--that we were all in sync.
[JESSIE JIANG]
That's a good tip.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
I often ask people at Google,
what do you think this job is,
after they've met
a few people.
Because sometimes they're not
sure what they're interviewing
for, because we have such a
diverse set of things in our
roles at the company.
[JESSIE JIANG]
That's true.
[DIANE GREENE]
Yeah, that outside perspective
gives you a lot of clues.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
When you think about young
people or developers just
starting out-- interested in
their skill sets, and what
experiences they
might have had.
Is there any particular point in
your career you would say,
that was when I really learned
the most, or realized this was
my passion.
[DIANE GREENE]
Well, I think for me, my passion
was always seeing
opportunities and
pursuing them.
When I would see, oh, this
could be done way better.
Or something new could be done
that would be really valuable.
That's what I've always
gravitated towards.
When I started working in the
tech industry, I found out
that it was really easy
to see something and
just run with it.
Because you could go build
something, without it costing
any money, particularly.
And if it solved their problem,
people would be
really happy.
Or if it produced something
that would be
valuable to the company.
So I got very excited about what
was possible in terms of
making a difference, without
having it to be highly
structured.
I think that's a huge
advantage of the tech industry.
And it just makes it much more
a meritocracy, merit based.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
But fast moving.
[DIANE GREENE]
Yes.
Actually, many years ago I was
on the board of a company in
the retail space--
and a very good company.
But it was amazing, the
difference in the pace between
the tech industry and
this company.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Yeah.
I think that has upsides
and downsides, right?
It's amazing to be in tech.
I don't think I would
go the other way.
But we can work in very short
cycles, and sometimes we get
short-sighted because we're just
trying to get the next
thing done.
When there are big tectonic
shifts happening.
And it's important to be
aware of both of those.
Do you have any tips for when
we're cycling really hard?
I'm sure you had this at VMware,
but at Google, in
particular, we sometimes feel
like we're running a hundred
miles an hour.
And it's important
to step back.
[DIANE GREENE]
Yeah.
I always tried to put in rituals
that periodically let
me, and some of the people
I work with, step back.
And so we had a once-a-week,
where once a month that
once-a-week would be a
little more on the
long-term than the immediate.
And then we had [? a cadence ?]
to some
off-sites we would do.
And also, one thing I really
liked about travel was when I
got on a plane, nobody would
be asking me for anything.
And I would really clarify my
long-term thoughts whenever I
traveled in a long flight.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Yeah.
Don't tell my husband that.
Sometimes I really actually
like traveling.
Even though that means I'm not
helping out at home as much.
Jessie, do you have any?
[JESSIE JIANG]
Yeah.
One of the things I love-- this
has actually come from
some of my team members.
And I was telling them, I'm
interviewing Diane--
I'm so excited.
And then, what are some things
you'd love to know about it?
And some of these are women.
And they said, they'd love to
know, what are some of the
things that you learned earlier
in your career, which
you thought are very
helpful for your
career, many years after?
Because I think many of the
people here at Google, we're
very young, just starting.
We'd love to learn
things from you.
Things you'd like to
advise us, at this
point of where we are.
[DIANE GREENE]
Oh, gee.
I sometimes feel like,
how can I give advice
to people like Google?
They're so talented.
But if I were myself giving
myself advice, when I started
out, what would I have
liked to have known?
What turned out to be true, is
when you produce quality
advancement on whatever
you're working
on, good things happen.
And to be reassured it that
is really the case.
And to just have confidence
to focus on doing very
high-quality, high-value work--
not just high-quality,
but also high-value work.
And to test out your ideas
about what's valuable.
I was worried that
things might not
get appreciated sometimes.
And they actually
did, always--
pretty much.
Or, I would leave.
And that is a piece of advice.
Is, if you're doing things and
they're not having the effect
that they should have.
They're being held back for some
reason that doesn't make
sense to you.
You just should go somewhere
else, where that's
not going to happen.
Don't stay in a situation
where you're frustrated.
And I never have.
I've always been very quick to
leave when I felt frustrated.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
This is like, you're being the
data analyst, where you then
said, hey, I could be
doing a lot more.
Computers could do a lot more.
You weren't feeling the
value and the impact.
[DIANE GREENE]
Yeah.
Well, I can remember a job I
had in a database company
where I was building some tools
that were doing some
really useful things for the
people in customer support.
And the customer support
people loved it.
But there were people that were
worried about the use of
these tools.
Or when I was a Naval architect,
I remember doing a
program to do the hydrostatic
analysis.
And the Naval architect I
was working for didn't--
this is very extreme-- didn't
quite trust computers yet, and
thought I should check
it by hand.
And that was a point when I
said, OK, I think I'll go
somewhere else where I can.
Anyhow, so it's just
a matter of--
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
That really resonates.
[DIANE GREENE]
--keep moving if you feel like
you're being held back.
But if you're doing excellent
work, chances are it will be
appreciated.
And just don't be afraid to
look around and see how to
make things better.
[JESSIE JIANG]
That's very good advice.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Yeah, that's great.
So, you joined the Google
board a year ago?
[DIANE GREENE]
Yeah, not quite a year ago.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Almost a year ago.
I'm sure, and you and I've
talked about this, you get a
lot of board invitations with
your really amazing
background.
And it is true, boards like
to have more women--
and they should.
How do you evaluate, and how
did we get so lucky?
What was it about Google,
besides being founded at the
same time, that made
you interested?
[DIANE GREENE]
Well, I feel very fortunate
to be on Google's board.
And I think boards are looking
for people that have
technology background.
They're looking for women.
They're looking for qualified
financial experts.
And so, when you can check all
three, it puts you in a
position to get board seats.
But at this point,
I'm full up.
I'm not joining any boards.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
We're not soliciting any.
But I think it must be a hard
choice, then if you have a lot
of options.
And I'm sure you have
many good options.
You only have so much time.
[DIANE GREENE]
Yeah.
Well, I think Google is one of
the most interesting and best
companies in the world.
And I was not looking to
join a board per se,
when Google came up.
I have so much admiration for
the founders of Google, the
CEO of Google.
And then Google as a company,
and what it's accomplishing.
And where it wants to go,
and what its values are.
It was an opportunity
I wanted.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Terrific.
We have a couple of questions
from Google Moderator.
One just came on from
someone with the
initials D S, in Texas.
Which I asked a little bit.
But I think people are very
interested in this, which is,
how did you keep yourself
technical as you moved up the
management chain?
A lot of people at Google,
I think, especially in
engineering, get worried
about this.
Did you keep yourself
as technical?
[DIANE GREENE]
Well, I have to say I
haven't written any
code in a little while--
more than a little while.
I do find it really important
to be able to--
I would check myself.
I would pick up technical
specs every now and
then, and read them.
And make sure I could
understand them.
And when I was finding
myself--
maybe I didn't know the
acronyms, or maybe there was
an underlying mechanism
that I didn't
understand how it worked.
I would go find technical people
to explain it to me.
Because it was a huge advantage,
particularly in the
partnering, to have
technical depth.
And then when you're negotiating
with people about
how something might work, if you
have technical depth, you
can negotiate it in a way
that it's likely to
have a lot more success.
And plus, it's more fun
to understand what
you're talking about.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Seems like a good practice.
Do you have any questions
on that?
[JESSIE JIANG]
I guess another question
I have is two
questions but related.
One is for people who are new
to management roles and
leadership roles, and especially
for women.
I wonder about what advice you
would give them when they take
a pretty important
career change?
Then there is a flip side
of the question is.
For companies who want to grow
women as a leader and
management, as a [? talent ?]
pool for the company, what do
you think the company can do
to help grow the women
talents, both in leadership
as well as in
the management rolls.
[DIANE GREENE]
This isn't exactly answering
your question, but you just
reminded me of something
I always did at VMware.
When I was in a room, in a
meeting, and there would be
women in the meeting.
And they knew they didn't have
to stay there, but I found
that they would always
enjoy it.
And once they'd experienced it,
they would realize it was
fun and rewarding to take
the lead on some things.
So that was something I used
to try and do consciously.
I was always very interested
in any women that were in
leadership roles or
in engineering.
Just checking in with them.
Because you just naturally feel
an alliance with them.
But in terms of going into
management, I think in
management--
I've always thought of myself
as, when I'm in management--
my job is to make everybody
successful.
I'm there to serve them.
They're the lucky ones.
I'm working like a dog to
make them successful.
And so I have to communicate a
lot to them, so they can do
their jobs well.
I have to coordinate, and
facilitate, and really lay the
infrastructure, so that they
can be successful.
And I think that's advice for
any manager, of course, not
just women.
But I think the biggest thing
is to just focus on what
you're trying to accomplish.
And don't let those nagging
confidence or fear things
creep in there.
And just keep your eye on what
you're trying to accomplish.
And keep your bar really high.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
That confidence piece can
be very important.
[DIANE GREENE]
Yes.
And you have to practice it.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
And then, one question which I
know you get probably a lot.
I certainly get it a lot.
Which is, how do
you do it all?
How did you found a very
successful company and raise
two children?
And sounds like you and your
husband were both working.
So, that's challenging.
I think the answer is different
for everybody.
But it is possible, is the first
thing, because you're
proof of that.
But any learnings
or tips, or--
[DIANE GREENE]
Yeah.
I think you're consciously
making compromises when you're
trying to work full-time and
raise your children.
And as long as you accept
that there's going to be
compromises, you can optimize
for what's important to you.
So being home for dinner
with my kids was really
important to me.
And that was how I set the
culture of VMware.
And being at special school
things was very important, so
I'd make a big show of that--
If I had to leave to go--
if I wanted to leave and
go and visit the
school for some reason.
But, at the same time,
after my kids were in
bed, I was on email.
To the point where people would
say, could you just not
send emails in the middle
of the night, Diane.
And I was like, OK,
I don't know.
I'd all save it up till
the next day starts.
But I threw a lot of energy into
being able to do things
across the entire day,
unless I was asleep.
But I did prioritize.
It's arbitrary how many hours
are in a day, so you have to
make a decision about which
hours you're going to put into
things that are not
work related.
And how you balance those.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
But the technology is actually
a great field, in terms of
some of that flexibility.
Many people at Google, men and
women, do get online at
different times.
And maybe leave early if their
child has something at school.
And then get back online.
I feel lucky I can do.
[DIANE GREENE]
Yeah, that's absolutely right.
And then, where you can, if
you can use your salary to
have food that's already made,
so that you're not having to.
You'd rather be with your kids
interacting, than cooking
dinner or cleaning the house.
So I definitely used my salary
to leverage my time.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
So you were only doing the
high-valued things that you
wanted to do.
That certainly resonates
a lot with me.
[JESSIE JIANG]
That's true, Definitely, yes.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
I think the thing is that,
this is for parents,
not just for women.
The president makes a point
of going to all his school
meetings, right, for
his children.
I think if leadership sends a
message that hey, you have
priorities at work, you have
priorities at home.
And being public about the
fact that, when you make
choices to go and be
with your kids.
is a good example.
[DIANE GREENE]
People are unhappy if
they're giving short
shrift to their family.
And you're not productive
if you're not happy.
So I think it's actually
a good trade-off.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
I think it's a good trend.
I'd like to see more of it.
I think we only have time for
one or two more questions.
Do we have any final industry
or technology?
[JESSIE JIANG]
Maybe I'll ask another
technology question.
Yay.
So, cloud, that's something dear
and very dear and close
to my heart.
But clearly there are many other
technologies that are
changing people's
lives every day.
In addition to cloud computing,
what are some of
the other technologies
are you really
excited about these days?
[DIANE GREENE]
The other--
I don't want to be a Google ad,
but I sure enjoyed driving
in the Google Driverless
Car recently.
I can't wait to get one.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Isn't it surprisingly normal?
You're just in a car and
it's driving itself.
[DIANE GREENE]
But in terms of just taking
it back to technology.
I do think human-computer
interaction.
I think having the use of
computers be human-centered,
rather than how it's been-- a
top down from the application.
It's a major shift, facilitated
by cloud,
facilitated by mobile,
facilitated by the sensors,
facilitated by being able to
integrate the processors.
In ways we haven't done before,
is just radically
improving what we're going to
be able to do as humans.
And it's really exciting
to be part of that.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Are you working on
new projects?
[DIANE GREENE]
Well, I have a new project.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Is it secret?
[DIANE GREENE]
Well, we'll see where it goes.
It's pretty junior.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
But you're basically a
serial entrepreneur.
[DIANE GREENE]
Well, I basically like
creating things
and building things.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Were you like that when
you were young?
[DIANE GREENE]
Yeah, I was always putting on a
play, or starting a team, or
making a kayak.
Or, yes.
I was always.
Build a dark room, yeah I was
always doing things, yeah.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
So you just--
that's what gets you going?
[DIANE GREENE]
Yeah.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
And when you think about
embarking on a new project,
does it feel like, I can't
believe I'm doing this again?
Or you just get new
energy, new ideas?
[DIANE GREENE]
I'm really happy to be doing it
again, but it's difficult.
Because I've got myself
committed to a
lot of other things.
And in the past, when I've
started a new project, it was
something new that I was going
to do next without, anything
else going on.
So this is an interesting
challenge for me.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
So every time, it's different.
Do you have a team?
Are you recruiting people?
I'm not looking, just
to be clear, Google.
[DIANE GREENE]
I have a few people that I'm
working with on some ideas.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
That's pretty exciting.
[DIANE GREENE]
But it's fun.
But we'll see.
I also think it's just wonderful
to have a group of
people that you have a long-term
relationship with.
Where day-in day-out, you're
developing and building
something new.
I think that's just extremely
rewarding.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
Yes, I agree.
[DIANE GREENE]
That sort of continuity.
[JESSIE JIANG]
So, any other closing thoughts
you want to share with
developers and engineers
out there, that we
haven't covered today?
[DIANE GREENE]
Just that, I think we're all
really lucky to be doing what
we're doing at this
point in time.
And I think it's wonderful
that it's
becoming much more balanced.
From a gender basis.
It's really fun to be sitting
here with two women, talking
about technology.
And so, just go and make sure
you enjoy yourself.
[JESSIE JIANG]
That's great.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
It's great work to do.
[JESSIE JIANG]
Yes, absolutely.
[CLAIRE JOHNSON]
All right.
Thank you, Diane Greene.
And thank you who tuned in for
our fourth episode of "Women
Techmakers".
Have a great day.
[JESSIE JIANG]
Thank you.
[DIANE GREENE]
OK.